hablamos de economía en directo américa
de france24 anhela landon con nosotros
en el estudio nuevamente volvió daniela
por donde estaba volví el buen hijo
vuelve a casa o bueno aquí le esperamos
con los brazos abiertos daniela rusia
respondió con sanciones el veto que
pretende imponer a la unión europea su a
su petróleo así desde raúl pues el
gobierno alemán reveló que el presidente
ruso vladimir putin hizo público un
decreto sancionando a aquellos
proveedores de gas europeos esta medida
prohíbe la exportación de productos y
materias primas a personas y entidades
descrita en una larga lista que incluye
entre otros a la parte por la cal
gasoducto yamal así como las filiales
europeas de la estatal gazprom ambas
transportan gas ruso a europa el
ministro de economía alemán cree que a
pesar de estas sanciones el suministro
está garantizado
esto significa que algunas de las
filiales ya no obtienen gas de rusia
pero el mercado ofrece alternativas
están recibiendo gas de otra parte
estamos siguiendo de cerca la situación
nos preparamos para esto el mercado del
gas puede compensar por completo la
pérdida de suministro desde rusia raúl
es que este sexto paquete de sanciones
que incluye un posible veto al petróleo
ruso es objeto de intensas negociaciones
en la comisión europea debido a la
reticencia de países como hungría
eslovaquia o república checa que son
altamente dependientes de este recurso y
venezuela- revocar lo que alguna vez fue
la política ha estado el presidente hugo
chávez cuando pues se hizo del estado
todas las empresas de servicios públicos
no porque venezuela ahora va a
democratic democratizar algunas empresas
estatales bueno pues el presidente de
ese país nicolás maduro aseguró que a
partir del próximo lunes estarán
disponibles en el mercado público de
valores las acciones de compañías como
cantv y movilnet de telecomunicaciones
así como otras de los sectores
siderúrgico y de petróleo gas y gas
aunque pedevesa no está incluida algunas
de ellas habían sido nacionalizadas como
ustedes lo dice raúl por el gobierno
hace más de una década
vamos a sacar entre 5% a 10% de las
acciones de varias empresas públicas
para la inversión nacional
fundamentalmente o internacional y usted
se podrá convertir en inversionista
necesitamos capital
para el desarrollo de todas las empresas
públicas necesitamos tecnología
necesitamos nuevos mercados y vamos a
avanzar
danny brasil cambia al ministro de
energía que llega con una polémica
propuesta ya hemos hablado muchas veces
acá de los precios de los combustibles
en brasil y es que en medio de esta
agitación política por ese aumento que
se ha dado en las últimas semanas por
parte de la petrolera estatal petrobras
el presidente ya ir bolsonaro reemplazo
a suministro de energía que era bento
alburquerque un almirante retirado de la
marina que ocupaba el cargo desde que
bolsonaro asumió en enero de 2019 el
nuevo titular de la cartera entonces es
adolfo tsáchila este es un funcionario
de alto rango del ministerio de economía
quien en su primera declaración pública
manifestó su intención de que sean
iniciados estudios para una posible
privatización de la mayor empresa del
país que hoy es mixta esta propuesta de
todas manera raúl requiere de la
aprobación del parlamento en el que
hasta el momento y una enorme mayoría
contraria al estado se deshaga de
petrobras porque tan polémico este raúl
bolsonaro ha atacado las abultadas
ganancias de la petrolera que sólo en el
primer trimestre fueron 38 veces mayores
a las de hace un año y por eso ha sido
crítico ferrero de los aumentos de los
precios de los combustibles y ha
propiciado la destitución de tres
presidentes de la compañía en poco más
de un año pero petrobras se defiende
diciendo que aunque es de mayoría
estatal también negocia sus acciones en
la bolsa de sao paulo en nueva york y en
madrid lo que a su vez impide una
intervención directa del estado
indicadores económicos y raúl si le
parece le quedó viendo los indicadores y
siempre nos interesábamos con la cifra
de una vez mil 574 millones de dólares
que ganó disney en el primer semestre
del año fiscal 2022 que terminó a
comienzos de mayo ellos tienen una
medición distinta esta cifra de 71 por
ciento mayor en comparación interanual y
los ingresos subieron 29 por ciento y
están impulsados por la división de
streaming que ya suma casi 138 millones
de suscriptores entre ellos yo ustedes
amigos diseños bueno dan y gracias por
toda la información me queda viendo
entonces
y nos vamos a donde porque seguramente
no la divina nos vamos hasta japón
daniela